من اين يتلقى
نتنياهو هذا الدعم الذي يجعله قادرا على
مواجهه اداره بايدن بهذا الشكل والاختلاف
معها حتى في
التفاصيل نعم تحياتي استاذ حسن وضيفك
الكريم
اي يعني هو سؤال جميل وعميق في نهايه
المطاف الذي يجب ان نقف على حيثياته يعني
هي ليست ربما المره الاولى التي يكون
نتنياهو في مواجهه اداره امريكيه بمثل هذا
الاحتدام ولكن اي هذه المره هنالك الكثير
يعني من المواقف التي يتخذها والتي يحاول
ان يتعنت بها بل ل نقل بكلمات اكثر ويتبنى
حرفيا
ال المواقف ال الاكثر يمنيه والاكثر تشددا
في داخل اسرائيل بشكل اضق يعني هو يقول
بطريقه دبلوماسيه ما يقوله بينغ فير بان
ان اسرائيل ليست نجمه في عالم الولايات
المتحده او او ما الى ذلك من امور الدافع
الاول الذي يجب ان ناخذه بعين الاعتبار هو
سر البقاء صراع البقاء نتنياهو في السنوات
الاخيره بشكل عام هو كل الدافع الاول
والغريزه الاولى الذي التي تحركه في نهايه
المطاف
هي راع
البقاء الهروب قضما من المحاكم
الاسرائيليه التي تنتظره في نهايه هذا
النفاق وله عبره اصلا في الكثير من
السياسه الاسرائيليون الذين عاقبتهم
اسرائيل بطريقه كهذه او اخرى وا يعني
انتهت حياتهم السياسيه بالسجون مثل اوربت
على سبيل المثال وبالتالي هذا الامر الذي
يحرك بنيامين نتنياهو قبل اي شيء اخر هذا
الدافع الاول وان كانت على مدى سنوات
كثيره ما قبل ذلك يعني حتى عام 2015
باعتقاد او حتى بدايه عام 2016 17 نتنياهو
كان استراتيجيا دبلوماسيا من الدرجه
الاولى تحركاته استراتيجيه لكن ما بعد ذلك
في السبع سنوات الاخيره تحركاته كلياتها
تكتيكيه تضع شخصه في المقام الاول